MARK MIRCHANDANI: In
Google Cloud Platform,
you'll need a billing account
to pay for any services you use.
Let's walk through how to
manage and set up permissions
for a billing account.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To start, we'll need to go
to the page for the billing
account.
On the left-hand side,
choose Billing, and then
click on Manage Billing
Accounts to see a list of all
your billing accounts.
Here, you can see each
billing account, as well as
the number of projects
associated with each one.
You can click on
an account to see
more detailed information
about the account
and get an overview
of the costs.
To manage this billing
account, click on Manage
in the top right.
From here, we can see
the associated projects
and manage permissions.
In order to make
sure others can see
costs for this billing account,
let's show how to add a user.
Click Add Member and type
in a user's email address.
Then, choose a role.
The default roles
for billing accounts
are viewers, users, and admins.
Billing account
viewers have access
to see the costs associated
with the billing account,
while users can view
costs and add projects
to the billing account.
Billing account
administrators can
do all of that plus manage
the billing account itself,
such as assigning permissions,
managing export settings,
or contacting billing support.
For this example, let's add
someone as a billing account
viewer so that they can see
the costs for this billing
account and all the
associated projects
without being able to associate
any additional projects.
You can also add a
group and assign roles
so that all users
in the group will
share the same permissions.
Users and groups can be managed
via G Suite or Cloud Identity.
If you want a user
to only see the costs
for individual projects rather
than all the costs for projects
attached to a billing
account, give them
the project viewer
role on each project
rather than billing account
viewer on the billing account.
Similarly for all
permissions, you
can even assign a group
to the project viewer role
and then add users
to that group.
Now, if you're a billing account
user or admin on a billing
account, you'll be able
to link that billing
account to a project
when you create it.
If you want to change the
billing account for a project,
head back to the Billing
Account Management page
and click on the Options
menu next to that project.
Choose Change Billing and then
pick a new billing account.
You can also disable
billing for a project, which
will shut down all paid
resources for that project,
so be careful.
Now, you should be able to start
managing your billing account
and assigning
permissions to them.